- Good morning Believe Nation!
Today's message is do extraordinary.
Over to you, Bear Grylls.
(rooster cawing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- And it was something I was told
on the first day of ever
joining the Special Forces,
and I remember at the end of this,
long selection process,
where 180 of us
had been whittled down
to four of us.
And this guy who I'd never seen before,
came in, stood in front of us,
and said this
"The difference between ordinary
and extraordinary,
is often just that little word, extra.
And the work I'm going
to now ask you to do
is not going to be ordinary,
it's going to be extraordinary.
But what's going to make the difference,
is when not one
ounce of you
thinks you can.
You're the people who over this last year
have shown me you can turn around,
and give me that little bit extra.
And it's that,
that's going to make your
work here extraordinary."
- To me extraordinary is
do you settle for good enough or not?
I think generally in life,
we tend to settle for good.
There's a book Good to
Great that talks about
the enemy of great, is good.
The enemy of great isn't terrible.
Because if something is really terrible,
you're going to fix it.
But if something is good,
then you let it slide,
you let it go through.
You know it would be
better but you're like
Eh, just it's good.
It's good enough.
Lets put it through.
And that's how too many
people live their lives,
they've settled for a good life,
instead of going for a great one.
Instead of going for an extraordinary one.
And so, you can apply it
to the work you're doing,
today you can apply it to
the videos you're making.
You can apply it to your
relationship at home,
with your wife, with your husband,
with your kids, with your
friends, with your parents,
with your customers you're
going to call tomorrow.
You can apply it to
everything that you do.
Do you settle for good?
Or do you go that little bit extra,
to make it extraordinary?
I think about the example, the
50 Cent video that we made,
and I told this story a couple times
but I think it really resinates here.
Where my team spent a lot
of time making a video,
50 Cent's Top Rules for Success
and I watched it, and it was
good, it was a good video.
I liked it.
But I felt it could be better.
I felt 50 had more in him,
that we hadn't uncovered,
that we should be able to find and share.
So then I spent extra hours of my time,
putting together the
research to make it happen.
I was doing the job of somebody on my team
because I thought it could be better.
I didn't want to settle for
having just a good enough video.
And so, it took a ton of man hours
to put this video together.
And when we launched it,
it had success.
And some how it go to 50 Cent.
I don't know 50 Cent.
But he saw it,
he liked it,
he shared it.
He wrote a blog post about it,
and tweeted it,
and I think he put it on his Facebok.
He shared it.
Now would the first
video have gotten to him,
and would he have shared it?
Maybe.
The one that was just good enough?
But he saw something extraordinary,
that he loved,
and he wanted to share it.
And that often, is what
makes a difference.
And you know,
you know when the thing you
made was just good enough.
You know when you're just skating by.
And you know when you
put everything you had
into making the next thing
you're doing amazing.
I want you to be proud of
the work that you're doing.
I want you to be able to show something,
that you made,
every day,
to want to give it to your grandkids.
I want my grandkids to watch these videos,
and first say how young I looked.
And then say,
"Man you really poured a lot
of energy and love into it,
we're proud of you."
And I want them to be
inspired and learn from it.
And it doesn't mean that,
I'm not still going to get better.
What's extraordinary for me now,
won't be in a couple years.
My best thing two years ago,
pales in comparison to what I can do now.
Because I've worked harder,
I've learned, I've built my muscles,
I'm better.
And I still strive to get
better, and better, and better.
There's is no perfection.
It's only something that we strive for.
So to encourage you, to stop
settling for good enough.
Look at what you've done today,
depending on what time
you're watching this video.
Look at what is on the schedule for today.
And don't go to sleep tonight,
until you can say you did
something that was extraordinary.
So the question today is,
I'm curious.
What have you done today
that's extraordinary?
Or what are you going to
do that's extraordinary?
Where you will not settle
for just being good enough.
Leave it down on the comments below.
Super curious to find
out what you have to say.
Also, I want to give a quick
should out to William Young.
William thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me.
And I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself!
And whatever your one word is!
Much love,
and I'll see you guys
again tomorrow morning
for another shot of an espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(typewriter typing)
- You know,
when you're chasing a dream,
I mean, when you're working hard,
chasing something you love,
and,
um,
completely dedicated.
It just happens.
You don't, you can't really notice it.
Even still to this day,
I'm in an amazing position in my life.
But I'm still working
like I'm not in this position.
- [Interviewer] Absolutely.
- I'm still working like none of this,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's just something I love to do,
I just keep pushing, I keep working hard.
I can't pin point an exact moment for you,
if anything I always felt
like it was happening
way back then.
And now it is happening.
But now I almost feel
like it's not happening.
I want to push to something else.
- [Interviewer] Absolutely.
- I'm always striving to push forward.
- The idea of being super rich,
the idea of operating from abundance,
the idea of going out and
making the world your prey.
The idea of building something
that no one else can believe in.
You can believe in.
God gives you this vision.
He gave it to you, and you alone.
You have to carry a
cross, for a little bit.
On your own.
People will watch you.
First they'll cheer.
Then they'll be upset with you,
Then they'll get real mad.
You'll be on their couch
and you get off their couch,
and you'll be this hero.
It's impossible,
if God gave you that vision
for you to fail at it.
Unless you quit.
So that's a very important lesson.
Because it seems like
in every business,
everybody quits all the time.
The success stories
are the ones that went the extra mile.
- You can be asking for assignments
that are above your level.
So there's work that you do at your level,
and there's work you do above your level.
And the only way you're
going to be promoted to do
work above your level is,
a, if you can demonstrate
that you're capable
of doing the work at your level.
And b, if you are proactive in seeking out
opportunities that expand your capability.
And give you a chance to work
above the level that you're at.
Nothing is going to happen
unless you take that initial action.
Nothing's going to happen.
Nothing's going to change.
Unless you put down that
pen, in the meeting,
and you sit up,
and you pay attention.
And you listen for your
opportunity to speak.
Nothing's going to happen.
Unless you push yourself to go in,
and make that ask for that assignment
that scares you to death.